[Music]
well gigi hadid and dialer cameron are
still hanging out this time with serena
williams check out the pair outside la
esquina in new york city and yeah
they're serena now if you're wondering
how Gigi and Serena know each other they
actually go way back
Serena presented Gigi with a glamour
women of the Year award and 2017 she's
always been a woman with goals and not
only beautiful on the outside but
totally stunning most importantly on the
inside Serena I just want to say you
have been such an inspiring force and
beautiful light in my life for so many
years and I can't tell you how honored I
am to call you my friend but back to
Tyler and Gigi the couple kept it casual
for date nights Gigi and a white tank a
pair of light wash jeans and gold slip
ons Tyler in a red tee grey shorts and
sneakers their latest date comes just
one night before Tyler's ex Hannah Brown
was named as one of the new contestants
on Dancing with the Stars I am so
excited for Elias to continue sharing my
life with America but in a different way
and that's through dance is still being
very vulnerable and sharing my story but
it doesn't have to involve a man right
and Hannah tell Dede she's actually
excited to put the focus back on herself
are you talking about my dating life
yeah but no I think I was put in this
position for some reason and I think
people need to see
people with this platform being really
authentic in real and showing real
emotions and I don't have to be anything
other than that and so I'm okay with it
fans were of course stoked that Hana
briefly reunited with Tyler after the
Bachelorette ended but just a day later
Tyler started hanging out with Gigi he's
single and I want to keep my options
open and he can keep his options I've
been a source recently told eg that Gigi
and Tyler are keeping things a casual
though but he is apartment hunting and
edmy see hmm
and with the pair heating up it's also
not looking like Tyler will be next
season's bachelor something like that
we're definitely way in the conversation
if Tyler is bouncing around from girl to
girl and loving the life and enjoying
the limelight which by the way good on
him that's fine if that's what you want
to do right now I don't blame him he's
probably enjoying life really really
well but that's not someone we're gonna
want him have his our bachelor all right
guys what do you think our gigi and
Tyler see is a real deal are you excited
to see Hanna on Dancing with the Stars I
know I am
let's talk though and for all the latest
keep it locked on all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now